okay four people joining this livestream
this is a discussion about language
development for from language and we
have a variety of topics here including
some that I think kind of complicated
and interesting so actually we have a
pre topic which came that attends and
over the weekend something that he has
some discovered for working on a book
he's writing um hey we're gonna pre
promote your book Etienne ah yeah cool
um so the the the idea is when you have
a formula but we see I think you could
do this for code as well
you're basically you know you're sort of
you're making a comment I mean this is
the modern world of typesetting with
gray levels and things which didn't
exist back in the day when you know
millions of years ago when when typeset
formulas were invented so to speak you
couldn't do gray level printing or not
not unreasonable way um so basically
what you're saying is we could imagine a
piece of code where we have essentially
an annotation in the code or in the
formula um and you know it's a form of
commenting basically yeah and I think
it's interesting I mean it you know it
it goes along with what that's just
pulling a random piece of code let me
just get a piece of code from somewhere
I'm sure I've got some from something
I've been working on recently let's just
pull something in here hold on one
second
um papa bar hey I'm just gonna pull this
up it's not really relevant but I'm just
gonna
yeah here we go so let's just pull in
this this function here um okay so what
we're saying is you know I could go
ahead and I could make that map indexed
I could turn that um you know magenta
for example where I to want to do so and
that magenta fication is not going to
change the when I entered send this into
the kernel it's just going to ignore
that right but the question is could I
put something in here where I for
example say in this you know I could put
a comment but could I also put something
where I say something like this or I put
something up here that says I mean just
to be crazy I could put an inline cell
here that says this is the best part of
the code and then I could make that for
example gray I could probably also make
it how do I make it text font um double
bar well here I can just say
I'm gonna do everything no it's not that
I don't know how to make them into a
text font how do I make that into a text
cell they're all seven or we can we
think I can just do that okay I did
something um okay so that will be the
color what it would look like I mean no
it didn't work it just didn't oh I see
it changed it into whatever I mean
whatever I can change the font yeah it
could be a cloud or something like that
yes yes it could be but the question is
semantically what is this right so in
other words we could give some nice you
know command key some nice way
right-click menu something like that I
mean this is sort of the inverse of
ionization right so just like I could
take piece of this code and I could say
I can eyes that right this is this is
something a little bit like ionization
now you know I can ization does not
survive evaluation nor would this
anybody commenting on want to comment on
this this reminds me of their language
captures it does yes it does I mean
let's look at language captions for a
second um
[Music]
well we have another fillet naeun that's
pretty that's pretty Swank um
and I think this is quite interesting I
don't know whether it goes above or
below
I mean clearly with language captions
there would suggest going above is
better
so the question is what would this look
like in terms of the and and the other
question is if I want something that
survives evaluation how do I do that
or do I not want it to survive
evaluation I mean we've had a lot of
trouble with comments from that what's
that go ahead probably if it's I mean if
it's part of the computation that it
would not survive I mean we survive when
you evaluate just by itself but it when
it's like you know X plus one and you
commented X then I assume that the
result will not be I mean a one plus two
when you commented one so what do you
say I mean look mostly these comments
disappear right did you understand what
I'm saying when most mostly most things
about code what what are you saying I'm
not sure what I'm saying that it's inert
right I mean one way I was seeing it was
just an inert wrapper and that would
change that wouldn't change anything
about the computation but it but but but
but it would just when the expression in
displayed so I guess you're saying
something need to be different right
because you're saying no but I'm saying
let's say we've got this okay
and if I put in here if I say here
labeled six hello right exactly it's
gonna look like that but that means if I
take this thing squared then hello you
know then that whole one here is squared
right so you have to make a decision are
you you know in that that's the thing
which we've always had trouble with with
comments because comments you know one
of the issues is when we do
transformations on code right the
comments are just not there
one of the things and probably this is
the wrong group to talk about this but
one possibility would be that since
we've got all these hashes present that
we could actually have this be a thing
that is maintained along with this code
but is not part of evaluation so in
other words it knows
I don't know how that can be done maybe
that's a stupid idea do you understand
where I'm going with this I mean that
that that that expression can have in
some hash table somewhere off on the
side it can say this was annotated in
this way
did you get what I'm saying anybody
understand here I think there are two
methods here one is doing it via the
front end like you did with map indexed
the other one will be to have something
that yes it doesn't survive evaluation
is there typesetting but as soon as you
evaluate it is just not there well I
know but but right now both these these
two do not survive evaluation right the
icon opens up the color disappears right
but you do them interactively not from a
matically that's true that's true I mean
I can eyes has a programmatic form okay
so here if I would say to this cell
convert to traditional form
I predict that will lose that color you
see
right okay so that's the main issue is
transformations which are made in the
front end we probably have the wrong
group to discuss this here
I mean I think this is a good idea okay
we got the wrong group to discuss it so
let's put it on an agenda for another
time and actually discuss it with people
who you know that the code assistants
people and people in the front-end group
make sense
yes but I'd like to I mean I think we
should call this
we can call this inline captions
okay and um we should discuss it uh I
mean I think for what you want here you
would be happy I'm guessing I mean this
is just a formula you typed in basically
right yeah but I did with code with old
phone so I would be happy with a
programmatic way of uh I mean I will
also be happy with non programmatic way
but you know it's bit nicer to have it
programmatically again I agree I agree
but as we've discussed I mean with icon
eyes we've got kind of a nice set up
because with icon eyes you can get okay
so let's let's remind ourselves how I
can eyes works
um the
uhh
you
we've got this if I now say percent
how does that work but if I copy it how
does this work
we've probably got the wrong team here
to discuss that how on earth does that
work because if we could make that work
here
wait a minute the icon eyes did not
survive conversion to traditional form
that's probably wrong Devon are you here
yes so you need to make a note of that
ha that's that's um attends earlier
right and you wrote this in this form
because you're trying to write these
formulas and that's that's cool that
you're writing these formulas in code I
usually yeah I really use old form but
the label you wouldn't work with labeled
right because it wouldn't it what form
right sorry which one often I use a hold
form just to you know to either a be not
evaluating I guess I could use strings
everywhere you know actually you're
teaching me something here because the
fact is you know in some of these
physics stuff I've been doing I've had a
hell of a time because I've been
entering formulas interactively and it's
probably stupid I should just use I was
yeah was doing that before and honestly
it's much better to do business code
right here because you can then reuse
pieces more easily and so on yeah hmm I
mean it's a little funky doing things
like this yes this is not actual code
yeah well but let me show you something
and see what what you think about it
this is in prototype build I think
somebody know how to do this the is the
tech input in prototype in the prototype
build because I think that might get the
best of both worlds um
in other words hopefully that will turn
into something so the question can you
get out the subscript thing from so if I
enter a subscript I here um well I think
subscrib actually did it interactively
and this yeah and it's only when I
copied the code that it dorita
okay so that does the right thing yeah
yeah so I mean I think the interesting
thing here is if we go to this um
so
in line tech input okay so here we've
got to let let's say I say list and then
I say frak you know X I don't really
know my tech but um I don't know what
I'm making this up
you
is this correct Tec do you know
been too long for me yeah I see okay so
that's beautiful so that that then okay
so let's put this in a list and just see
what it does
okay so what's interesting there is it
entered it's not obvious this is correct
it entered even in this form as an
inline cell I don't think that's right
and Devon that's for you to note but
look at this isn't that cool but that
basically was something how did you
start
what sir how did you start how did you
start to type in well I used I mean it's
gonna have a command key but but right
now it's in line tech input okay
and now let's see whether this works if
I say T um me too how does this work do
I do another when I say team u team uni
like that that's nice
now what's this gonna turn into and what
the heck is that I guess no substrate
was - right but now if what I did
instead was so what you're saying is if
I do the tech input of something like um
I squared okay I see I see
this is great actually because the
primary use here I wasn't even thinking
about this case the primary uses the you
know that the tensor is and then here I
would do inline tech input I mean this
is its primary uses is is for inline
input not in code but I'm realizing from
what Etienne is saying this is also
useful right because this gives you away
um to you know if if you have a nice
some um whatever it is
you know I'm sure there's things we can
do here that are not easy for us to do
well and you know vertical bar you know
let's say the set you know such that bla
bla bla bla bla z : mapping I don't know
what it is this guess right arrow
it's a maps to ok maps to ok so
something like this lovely and that's
completely meaning us for us and we get
all the spacing wrong because we'd think
of this as a you know as something
meaningful to us whereas this is just
thinking of it as sort of pure math gunk
so to speak this is great I mean this
makes use of stuff that was built 25
years ago for our weird converter to
from tech to boxes which we should have
incorporated in the product a long time
ago ok so anyway but for another meeting
all right let's talk about array
broadcasting okay well I mean I whatever
I don't think that's the main point the
main point here it is that's why we come
from yeah I understand ok so let's so I
extracted two topics so it's I must say
it's a very beginning even for us that
we think about that having a meeting
with telly
it's about 10 telly has burnt of IDs
anyone to explore them or write a blog
post about it which i think is great
because I mean especially for podcasting
from I reg reg 8 is kind of easier much
easier problem so the questions are its
are just they yeah what is this I don't
for non tech it's it's coming in version
12 to is the
answer it's not not available yet um the
for the tech yeah yeah right it's our
own code code base completely um okay
sorry but back to this so yeah yeah so
it's quite happy that I tell you I mean
he has been thinking about this for a
long time and he wants to to write a
blog post about it and and I think I
think it's good to explore a bit you
know everything you could do with with
this concept to go beyond what other
people do because what kind of seeing it
from the perspective let's see what
other you know I don't really care try
to at least match them but you know
maybe you can go beyond so anyway it's
very in its infancy at least for
broadcasting for the aggregate this is
much more straightforward okay so I'll
just try that let's frame for everybody
what the heck the point is here so the
issue is there is a notion of I hate the
way this works but anyway whatever
there's a notion here of of what at what
level does what level of aggregation
occur right yeah on what i seized yeah
what axes do we aggregate okay so what
does aggregate mean how does it compare
to map so this is quite different this
is for functions that you know take take
a list of stuff and return a unique
thing like you know mean we take a list
of numbers and return a scalar so so so
I don't think oh yeah I guess I guess
map map would would work as well yeah
are there so
but lower to apply this is an apply at a
particular level right so let's take
this example here right so what you want
to do what what is this in fact doing is
this a transpose and apply or what is it
this is like a map actually this is map
of max over this three map and a live
stream is commenting that he asked for
these levels back functions four years
ago for things like mean and variance um
I think this yeah it's very useful
things yeah so this is a bit like
flooding in certain some operation in
the middle
so before you construct the new array
you are allowing yourself to do
something with their vectors there boy
we should be looking at this we should
have discussed this more actively and
then probably we've gone through some of
this but but um it could have more
discussion of this I hope yeah Devon
that's another thing for you please we
could we make sure we process this and
see what should be on these agendas if
it hasn't been already okay so I'm sorry
go ahead what were you saying here me I
was trying to compare these two flooding
which is another operation that kind of
these structures right but of course it
does nothing in between
right so tell me what the definition of
this thing is in terms of I don't care
that works the same segregation layer
it's just super confusing
they just explain what this thing does
in general all right so so so you
basically the third argument is the
least of axes on which the array will be
contracted aggregated so talk tensors
for a second what would this be in terms
of tensor indices what is this doing
well I'm not very good at this language
can you can you yes I think this is
trying my physics is so so micro you see
it here right okay
mind yeah I was never you know this type
of physicist the UM okay anyway go ahead
um I think this is trying to generalize
the second argument of flatten which is
super powerful two other functions the
idea that you can say take levels of the
array and create a new array with new
levels which come from the previous one
in this way okay I mean I remember it
took years to come up with that second
argument of flatten the full second
argument of flatten I remember working
on that for a long time okay so let's
let's so let's see whether it is exactly
the same as that second argument flatten
whether it whether what this is is
essentially an applied flatten type
construct that it is go ahead yeah yeah
I guess I guess that's kind of what it
is yeah I mean kind of a trance I mean
flatten is doing a bit of transpose as
well right that's the idea I suppose is
a particular case of cotton yes so
frightening here flirting with a with
the second argument it has which is so
powerful the last version that's
incredibly powerful okay by combining
all levels as I try to make each level I
in the list so here you start with an
array with many levels and then you are
going to take several levels and
construct a new array with combinations
of these exactly exactly so the only
difference is that well flatten is doing
is it's doing the null operation so to
speak it's just doing nothing with the
elements right so in general what one's
talking about is doing something where
one is performing an operation to so one
is on on this sub sub sub array one is
doing an operation so Sandra is
commenting that that total has a total
as one yeah you cannot have although
it's level 1 N 1 through n 2 which in
our case the list would be full of N 1
and
and to write and you would need a span
to say anyone to end I don't even know
for total whether that aggregate whether
it's aggregator I don't quite understand
what it would do if you give two
disjoint levels does that make sense for
total help help me out here with yes yes
okay okay let this thing in term
dimension look at the last example just
in terms of dimension
I read you guys demo 3 4 5 ok if you
just put a 2 what is doing is that it's
kind of you consider the transpose I
guess on this case like the 4 would be
put you know 4 & 3 will be swapped and
any will do a map you could see it like
that I mean not a map but it would do
the mean you're saying okay so in terms
of sort of the skeleton of a tensor this
is a 3 4 5 cancer 3 4 5 all right you
know it and what you're saying is if I
say mean it at level 2 yeah then when I
get back as a 3/5 array
exactly exactly but let me understand
what that means for the deeper levels
here because let's say I make an array
okay let's let's make our 3 4 5 array
okay so let's let's just say I don't
know subscript it's just to make it a
little bit more readable
um do I do this to kind of just do hash
hash there um 3 4 5 okay there we go
okay so there's our 3 4 5 array okay now
what does it mean to mean it at level 2
right so yes this is something I have
investigated in the past so the idea
here is that not only you have to say at
which level you are applying me you also
have to say how do you treat the
elements you find exactly exactly how
far down do you just pick up so if I
were to take level 2 of this right so
let's take this thing at level 2 the
okay so what is that that is the level 2
sub tensors of this sub arrays of this
thing and so then what I would be doing
is I would be meaning each of these so
be mapping mean against each of these
that correct
I mean is not doing at level one by
default so it's gonna be weird ok so
then let me not use mean man let's just
use F okay so there I've got that so
that means that is saying at level two
you're saying this is an applying the
operation at level two which is
something I could just do with apply yes
in this case you would map me yeah right
it was he a map so so this is equivalent
what I got there is equivalent to saying
on the original array Oh super glue I
think in bracket can you break it no
level but there isn't a meaning to that
look look if I say 296 here
the whole point is wait a minute now I'm
even more confused why isn't that
different these another one through oh I
got it wrong okay I could have been one
and two yeah yeah I got that wrong okay
I got that wrong okay so there's the
result okay so what this is saying is
that is the equivalent of saying map on
map of F on 2% to 96 at level 2 correct
yes everyone in this case why was the
mention of that what is the dimension of
that three four five to ninety six is a
dimension the result yeah
oh the dimensions of the result what is
the result is pre-fire I would say yes
you know it's going to be safe for in
this case how do I get it to be three
[ __ ] I can't get it to be three five
because this thing's not our living one
living one why would that be three five
well not in this case with F there's no
way to do it with with young it'll work
why because me would be able to take the
the mean of our list of vectors oh I see
because me and return something which
it's because mean has a sort of
Pseudolus stability it will return
something of that with that shape right
so the question here is that there are
functions that will do different things
depending on how they treat their
elements and the most famous case for us
is outer that's why outer needs these
integers at the end yes so I call this
effective ranks and so some when do we
have functions that deal with a race
they might be doing things differently
depending on how they treat their
elements okay okay so you're saying
there are different cases functions that
to use a term that we used in version
one design redentor Phi that is they
drill into a they burrow through an
array versus and I can't use that word
it's too stupid functions that burrow
basically well that they're different
cases
how do functions treat a list right they
could be list of all they could
essentially auto map ie be list of all
they could do the kind of thing that
mean and total do they could be they
could be Auto apply at level Auto apply
what is it doing it's what what is the
correct thing it's it's doing Auto apply
at level one right I think that's right
am I am i right here what do you have in
mind which function you think over
thinking of total right so the total of
a b c d will give us a C plus B plus D
which is otherwise known as saying apply
F to this thing no it's not doing that
at all it's doing some kind of
transposed that's doing the kind of
thing that this aggregate function is
thinking about doing so to speak
well it's it's flying glass at low zero
something that doesn't really belong
there you know what let me let me put
this let me let me do something
different here let me make a separate
notebook Devin do you have you know we
really should prepare for these things
where we expect to put the notebooks
that we create um okay let's say array
aggregation oh one okay let me move this
stuff over
well we could just stay okay here okay
so first question is how do functions
treat how to functions you know from the
beginning treat a list so to speak like
total does that thing but that's very
different from what a list of all
function like log here would do this
right yeah she's not a contracting
aggregation function I'm sorry
aggregating function log right but this
is doing some kind of aggregation sounds
really amending that we try a few
examples here and I think we should um
I'm sorry I'm gonna replace this with
ABCD so that I don't have to do
arithmetic in my head to understand
what's going on
okay so at level two what I would assume
is this is going to give us a plus b c
plus D yes down to level two I would
assume it's gonna give us a plus B plus
C plus D the whole ball of wax okay good
and what I would assume the default is
is the default I think is this level one
thing if I'm correct yes so what
proposing is an extension of that so all
of this can I'll see you there
actually except the two there's going to
be a span right okay
so let's try to understand what you're
suggesting here meanwhile I also want to
understand um okay so flatten here at
level two would do absolutely nothing
what well well did that to flatten
requires either a number or a list of
lists the case of a list I'm not sure
it's always well-defined you can flatten
two levels or you can use the list of
lists rotation to specify happiness
levels - levels right so if I would say
here
flatten one - like that that should do a
complete flattening right if I were to
say flatten two to - I don't think it
does anything does it
no they cannot be repeated the numbers
cannot be repeated okay but you can do
to one and then there will be an
effective transpose before right because
it's putting right its first transposing
and then flatten I see okay
or you can do list to least one and
that's a true transpose
okay so I understand that so that will
put level two at at level one and level
one at level two okay